foreign
[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to talk about an article that was
at least a couple days ago here from
variety that is in conjunction with a
fandom study that's talking about how
nearly 40 of Marvel fans are uh showing
franchise fatigue perhaps not happy with
the MCU John how are you I am so
fatigued to even thinking about it how
are you yeah I'm fatigued over the MCU
that's right man 40 of fans say they're
tired of only only one only women
surveyed 5 000 men who hate women ages
13 to 54. this is the only requirement
is that you hate women so this is an
interesting breakdown it's a big complex
but I didn't find it really interesting
and I was surprised too because this is
normally the kind of thing you hear
about from
other news sites you don't really hear
about it from variety of all places what
fandom did was it took a study of 5 000
entertainment and gaming fans between
the ages of 13 and 54 years old leave a
like by the way as well as fandom terms
proprietary insights from its platform
of over 300 million monthly users across
250 000 different wikis So within this 5
000 people they broke them down into
four groups Advocates intentionalists
culturists and the flirt now I could
just read what variety put down here but
I think it'd be more fun to see John
explain each one of these categories on
his own yes because what are The
Advocates John The Advocates are your
koi genres of the world you're people
who are dedicated to this particular IP
and who are going to be there regardless
okay then the intentionalists are your
people who have an interest but are more
uh going to decide based off of Good
Word of Mouth positive reviews and other
factors like you know filmmakers
involved or actors you know different
kinds of clout alongside their
investment in whatever the property is
and then you have your culturalists who
are more going with the flow of just
what is trending what is most popular
and then you have the flirts who are
just out here trying to dabble in
anything and see who they might strike
up a kinship with so that's more about
the personal experience than it is about
the property whatsoever well yeah well
done thank you it's actually easier to
understand than a lot of the terminology
I read this service yeah but now let's
go back to a little more technical we're
just gonna read the paragraph here and
we're going to share our opinions on
this having more Advocates and
intentialists in a fandom as Marvel with
66 percent does over DC with 61 percent
can be an advantage for a franchise but
it's not quite that cut and dried
according to fandom study 81 of Marvel
fans would watch anything related in the
franchise while 67 percent of DC fans
would do the same conversely just 38
percent of Marvel fans say their focused
on specific superheroes rather than the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
compared to 57 percent of DC fans who
care more about one or two superheroes
rather than the full DC Universe this
could be a major factor in why only 20
percent of DC fans say they're fatigued
by the number of releases in a year but
they have concluded is that nearly 40
percent of Marvel fans are feeling
fatigued by it now I guess the question
comes into to play here of of this
feeling which I'm still like 5 000
pieces I mean I guess five thousand
people is a reasonable amount to discern
that number it's a big age range sure
yeah I mean you know there are millions
of people who watch it I suppose you
could draw at least a notable
cross-section worth examining out of 5
000 people even if it's not the complete
ratio I guess it is a fascinating thing
to look at recently we got Bob Iger who
stepping back in the CEO of Disney and
everything at Disney seems to just not
be hitting the marks that they want to
be hitting all across the board and that
seems like it's Marvel included not long
ago Grace Randolph was even reporting on
how there's been a lot of I don't know
where the source comes from but it was
taken off that uh there's been a lot of
script troubles and production problems
with Marvel as of late and we we've all
heard about what's been going on with
the blade situation as well even black
panther wakanda forever while doing
great numbers is not on track with
matching the first Black Panther movie I
feel like there's a variety of me for
crying out loud you don't even have your
your main character returning this time
around a lot of it contributing fact
there's a lot of contributing factors
and maybe it is fatigue maybe it is word
of mouth and like I think if we really
you know separate ourselves because I've
liked most of the Marvel things that
have come out for sure but there's been
a decent amount of ones that just didn't
quite hit the mark in the way I was
hoping for especially when it comes to
some of the finales of these shows the
movies
like one of them in one or two that
would be like I love loved this movie I
guess the question comes out to is it
fatigue over the amount of releases or
is it fatigue over the fact that maybe
the quality and the overall reception to
them isn't as impactful or as Grand as
Marvel once was on a consistent basis
you know because it seems like there's a
lot more complaints about the actual
execution of a lot of these films even
for wakana forever a movie that we loved
you know I I very much heard the other
side you know that seems to be a lot of
people too yeah and I mean I guess my
question about this study because I
think this is pretty fascinating when
you look at the way it breaks down I
mean it makes a lot more sense than the
headline of like 40 of Marvel fans are
disappointed what have you believe but I
want to know which pockets of the
overall picture they got this 40 percent
out of if it's all your Advocates and
intentionalists so to speak and it's
like 40 of our 36 percent of those
people are disappointed I feel like
that's a bit more dire than just like
the overall scope of everyone engaging
with Marvel contributing to that number
if that makes sense it's like if you
have a bunch of fair weather fans and
Casual fans who are also saying like
yeah I don't know
that anymore like that softens the blow
a bit to me so I would like to know yeah
whose disappointment we are gauging but
even so I mean like 36 comparatively
doesn't seem dire and it does you know
seem reflective of a of a phase that is
about growing pains and that has had a
lot of you know restructuring you know
necessitated by outside circumstances
not even within the hardcore Marvel
Community like I'm addressing things
where like I hear the responses coming
and I'm just talking about the
objections that I've heard we've had our
retorts and our responses a certain
objection some we agree with some we
were just like oh no let me think about
it one thing is is it has felt for a lot
of people like the direction hasn't been
that clear I can't imagine that what if
more of them were really hidden the mark
for a bigger audience that's you know
this is a large percentage of people and
Marvel's in an odd position where like
even though part of the charm is that
you can appeal to different pockets of
your fan base with each different care
character in each different aesthetic it
seems like the goal is to appeal to
everyone with all of them and that's I
think the harder the more properties you
put out in a year and they're putting
out more than ever before right now in
terms of both the Disney plus and the
films definitely indicative I would say
it falls right in line with the overall
conversation surrounding phase four
however your personal feelings pan out a
lot of people yeah have kind of decided
that this is one of the rockier phases
36 percent dissatisfaction rate seems
about on track yeah sure I actually get
it I'm gonna look to me I'm like no I
get it nah dude there's a lot of Marvel
in it and
like we love Marvel but at the same time
I'm like well yeah I mean a lot of the
like I could think I love werewolf by
night I love wakana forever the last one
I was like I truly loved was Spider-Man
no way home and there's been a lot in
between them when it comes to the shows
that have come out I'm like I loved
episodes of those shows I love the show
overall
much different question you know and I
could kind of say the same thing about
Star Wars yeah absolutely I think and I
think Star Wars has less of a of a a
consistent track record at least what do
you guys think are you part of this 36
are you feeling the superhero fatigue do
you think that this fatigue would not
perhaps feel as tiresome if you felt the
properties themselves were hitting the
mark a little stronger leave your
thoughts down below go ahead subscribe
leave a like
um
I'll catch y'all soon
[Music]